you're boneless a bone-in chicken guy I
gotta ask just to make sure uh eat
chicken because I'm gonna have a
vegetarian but boneless thank you all
right I remember my feelings yeah me too
me too I don't know why though I guess
it's these it's just easy I don't want
to deal with this bone [ __ ] I remember
when Felix first said that he was an
epic pescatarian I was like is that like
a different level of pescatarian it is
I'm better than everyone when did you
become a pescatarian uh
there's a lot of fake chicken that
tastes the same yeah but really really
where everywhere and the grocery store
you can buy it yeah does it and it taste
the same it tastes the same was it
because you haven't had it in so long
you're like this is honestly it tastes
the same okay okay I I think the thing I
can't get over
um that will always taste weird for me
is like vegan cheese like I've had very
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's never good I'm
telling you halloumi cheese is the best
it's like yeah you find a good vegan
pizza that's rare it doesn't happen no I
do like vegan Burgers actually vegan
burgers are really good yeah you can get
some really good ones yeah I agree um we
went to a vegan place that was okay we
had vegan burrito yes that's right yeah
this is pretty good they put coriander
in it oh yeah [ __ ] you don't like
corianders why is that like a weird
thing everyone gets quiet
I think too much coriander is yeah I
mean it's genetic right if you like
coriander or not I think apparently but
I feel like people is it yeah
you can get a DNA test and in the DNA
test it'll tell you if you're more
likely to like I don't like ketchup
that's that's genetic no no no no
no
no
no
ketchup
like condiments like at all like mustard
not actually actually Japan has changed
me because like mayonnaise [ __ ] like
no it hasn't I still don't eat [ __ ]
condiments
not too much but I like it you know it's
like keeping mayonnaise just like I've
realized that it's just like the
superior mayonnaise of course you like
the mayonnaise here
yes what was that what the [ __ ] was that
what was that what the [ __ ] was that
what was that
it was like I'm gonna say something
I I haven't gotten used to it yet what
the [ __ ] what do you mean you like the
UK mayonnaise so creamy I'm not yeah
that's what makes it good you like the
watery ass like I want them
filthy that's what I'm using the one
that plops on okay
another another Japan central question
obviously con beanies right everyone we
all love them yeah what's your go-to
food in combini the onigiri which which
one tuna yeah you can't go wrong with it
yeah especially when they like actually
when you get the one in three on a giri
where they actually balance all the
ingredients well because I feel like two
out of three times you get it you're
like I've had four bites of rice yeah
it's almost like
it's like there's no tuna in this I'm
dying
I don't know yeah I love the egg and uh
tuna sandwiches again tuna it's like uh
half tuna half egg have you met how you
missed this sandwiches are so
disgusting in UK okay
which ones wait have you had a Tesco
meal deal with any of those well you
know I had that yeah that's why I'm
asking
how long did you live in the UK's
message
me and he's like he's like how was the
Tesco meal deal I'm like yeah it's
pretty good and then I gave him the
selection and I'm like what do you do
you rate my selection I feel this is
like I've never had this I don't know I
was like bruh
isn't everyone raving about the Tesco
meal then I'm just like yeah have you
had any of the store-bought sandwiches
I've tried it once and they were just
not so this is this one sandwich from
this one mysterious [ __ ] place and
you've written off the entire country of
sandwiches have you ever been wait did
you ever go to Greg's
oh my God what were you doing for like
eight years I don't know what did you
eat okay tell me what you eat right now
in the UK what did you do you know what
take a private jet out loud
it looks so bad you know I feel like
people would be more receptive if you
like I never want to speak English in
the UK all right fine I will never try
Greg's what
sausage rolls don't taste like okay no
no I I forgive you on that because I
think that it's where it's the it's the
bakes where it's all at the you know the
the bean cheese and sausage melt yeah my
go-to my go-to order at Greg's is like I
might have a cheeky sausage roll but
I'll normally get such a cheeky sausages
but gotta get maybe I'll get three and
either I get two cheese and onion
pasties I [ __ ] love the cheese oh
I'll get to uh cheese uh beans and
sausage when do you enjoy this is like a
hangover food or it's got to hang out
with food if I'm feeling like I gotta
you know get back in touch with my UK
Roots you're on the roads you're taking
on a road trip you stop at uh everywhere
because I like going to Japan and never
having sushi or something or it's like
never going to like uh
yeah
wait what did you eat when you're in the
UK honestly I was so confused for the
longest time like what the [ __ ] do
people eat
I don't what do you mean whatever you
guys talking about the meal that I'm
like oh so that's what people do a lot
of services
I don't get it Marsha Cooks but a lot of
times we go and I'm like what the [ __ ]
this takes forever
there's a genuinely like a few months
back there's an article being like uh
doctors were like begging Tescos and
stuff to stop doing meal deals was so
cheap yeah because they're so bad for
you and that people were buying them
like every single day for lunch because
you get like it's all processed and you
know you get a bag of crisps or
something as well so it's not good but
man with the value there yes I know
three pound if you have a Tesco Club
card now but three pound fifty you get a
big sandwich a big bag of crisps or
fruit or whatever and you get like a
premium drink you know one of the like
not just not just water well you can get
like the innocent smoothies you ever
drink those oh those are good you get
like an innocent smoothie in your thing
and those are like three pounds on their
own normally it's a joke yeah so you can
get that in the real deal I guess I've
missed that out okay
what fast food places or anything did
you eat out never uh we should get
uh this is like I feel like I'm asking
Bill Gates the price of chicken nuggets
tell me uh
yeah sure okay
yeah I guess we do it's uh it's just
decent yeah it's pretty with the better
out of all of them did you ever get Uber
Eats or anything like that well delivery
right yeah delivery yeah yeah it's it's
good there is now an obsession with uh
Japanese food in the UK you might like
there's all the Japanese chains popping
up oh really yeah E2 uh Wasabi um
there's another um
okay
wagamama is like UK style yeah Wasabi
has some okay stuff like if you if
you're craving that Sushi it's like not
bad but obviously compared to Japan yeah
yeah yeah I love these restaurant names
by the way yeah
it's a little like so surface level I
went to Japan once yeah yeah wagamama
shellfish
all right we'll go to Tortilla
everyone's obsessed with that vegan
place what's the one vegan place
everyone's obsessed with I always see
lines for it's red and it's like a one
word [ __ ] uh yes yes
um what's it called I don't know what
you're talking about oh you've seen them
everywhere what is it called it's gonna
drive me I didn't even know there was a
vegan chain so
so vegan chain fast food UK it's gonna
come out right away
uh it did not come right away
[ __ ] God it was Leon
yeah Leon is what I'm saying about well
they have a lot of vegan options but
it's not exclusively vegan I was wrong I
thought it was because I only ever saw
vegan stuff on the menu but I guess this
chicken stuff everything added more yeah
but it's pretty popular I know in the UK
this yeah so many of them it's really
good yeah on all the UK vloggers always
talk about how they love really yeah how
lovely aren't so lit trying the one
pound a day challenge
have you seen this video yeah this is
who did it again was it Charlie days
Charlie day that's it
yeah
this is oh my God it's so hard to
survive on one pound we're gonna use it
how is the homeless do this how do they
do it
when some shopping just gonna get water
from my tap and have a shower
can I drink my filtered water
how am I gonna do this
back like a wave of memories